what was your involvement in the
appointment of Lord green did you know
about his links with hsbc Suisse and
these allegations of tax avoidance and
evasion that are now coming out five
years later I'm exuma Green was a very
effective trade minister and look I'm
making it absolute cardinal rule as
Chancellor as indeed previous dancers
have not to get involved in know the
details of any individual or any
individual companies tax affairs and I
think if you think through the
consequences of someone in my job
actually knowing the tax affairs of you
or this company I think we will be
heading down a very slippery slope and
Britain so I don't do that my
predecessors don't do that I think it's
a very important constitutional
principle in Britain do you regret that
they've given given how much of a fuss
now is happening around HSBC and these
kind of tax affairs you know would you
rather in retrospect have known you know
more about that and said listen that's
that's a bit kind of worrying we can't
get involved as I say my responsibility
is to set the tax laws of the country
and I've taken more steps than any
previous Chancellor to make sure tackle
aggressive tax or planning that we deal
with tax evasion that we get money
indeed from swiss bank accounts I'm also
responsible for making sure that HMRC
our revenue collection service has the
resources to go after people who are
evading their taxes and they are doing
that they've got those resources and
they're collecting more money on behalf
of everyone else who pays their taxes as
I said anything is right for a chance to
check ur to get involved in the tax
affairs of an individual I think when
you think through the consequences of
that you realize what a disaster would
be
country so I I don't do that my
responsibility is to the British
taxpayer in general to make sure we have
a good tax system and that everyone's
paying their fair share we've just heard
from Lord thankies given an interview in
which is essentially admitted to what he
calls vanilla tax avoidance he was a
form of Treasury of the Conservative
Party that surely looks extremely
embarrassing that one of your owners key
member of your party has admitted and
said basically everyone is avoiding tax
but Ed Miliband might blunder in and
make accusations about individuals and
claim to know about their tax affairs as
the chantix checker I take a different
approach which is I don't comment on the
tax affairs have been do join never have
and I then intend to start now my
responsibility is to make sure that
aggressive tax planning is thwarted we
are very successful now of doing that
the way that wasn't the case on to the
last government of course my
responsibilities to make sure those who
evade their taxes are pursued and hunted
down and made to pay up and again we've
had success in doing that so those are
my responsibilities and those are
ultimately what the country as a whole
is interested are people paying their
fair share are we collecting the taxes
we need and are we investing in their
economy in the future so that we are
able to afford our great public services
but it's still just study undermining
it's a key member of your party saying
everyone is doing it even generally
speaking is all about individual saying
generally everyone's up to this we're
very clear that we don't approve of
aggressive tax planning and aggressive
tax or because that we will take steps
to stop it happening and we have and
will continue to do so we are also clear
that tax evasion is illegal and because
it's illegal we will pursue you together
the efforts of myself and hmrc mean that
up to 85 billion pounds
taxes have either been collected or
protected and of course we do this
because we want a strong economy way in
general taxes can be as low as possible
cost at the same time funding vital
things like the health service in our
education system I make a broader point
of course none of this is sustainable
without a long-term economic plan that
has a growing economy and successful
businesses like the business here
Siemens and Lincoln that we're this
thing today